und jetzt das heute journal
mit kay sölve richter und christian
sievers guten abend bitte bleiben sie zu
hause das ist der dringende rat der
experten an die menschen in teilen
deutschlands heute abend und in dieser
nacht und er hat nichts zu tun mit der
pandemie und fiel mit dem wetter
deutschland stehen ungewöhnliche wetter
extreme bevor im norden und der mitte
des landes sehr viel schnee und fieses
eis im süden frühlingsgefühle die
aktuelle lage zeigt anna maria schock
wenn schnee auf eis trifft dann geht
nicht mehr viel
selbst dann nicht wenn man nach hilft
auf der a4 zwischen erfurt und weimar
stehen die meisten fahrzeuge heute abend
still dauereinsatz für abschleppdienste
in vielen teilen deutschlands so wie
hier im landkreis havelland in
brandenburg kommt es immer wieder zu
glätte unfällen das war absehbar sagen
einsatzkräfte und raten zu hause bleiben
denn es geht ja also da gibt es keinen
tipp bei den straßenverhältnissen
da habt ihr gesehen der winterdienst ist
durchgefahren es verändert sich so gut
wie nichts
es ist eben eine eiskalte fahrbahn und
da ist feuchtigkeit drauf und unterm
schnee ist die kälte auch noch schön
isoliert runter und unterm schnee eis
und das ist ganz einfach tödlich
eisige kälte schneestürme und glatteis
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt dieses
extreme wetter hält im norden und der
mitte deutschlands weiter an
auch der schienenverkehr ist zum teil
massiv eingeschränkt einige
zugverbindungen schon jetzt gesperrt
überall dort wo wir glauben dass die
unwetterlage sich zuspitzt haben wir
unser gerät disponiert das sind
schneepflüge die sind im einsatz wir
haben im norden deutschlands vorsorglich
fernverkehrs linien aus dem fahrplan
genommen einfach weil die sicherheit
unserer fahrgäste aber auch unsere
eigenen mitarbeitenden
oberste priorität hat wir wollen dort
nicht auf freier strecke liegen bleiben
deutschland zweigeteilt im norden und in
der mitte schneeverwehungen und eisregen
im süden fast frühlingshafte
temperaturen
dahinter steckt ein
seltenes wetterphänomen ein seltenes
wetterphänomen bringen will katja hornuf
damit dazu unsere zdf meteorologin
hallo katja so was schon mal erlebt so
kann ich ein so heftiges hoch das eben
sehr kalte luft mit eisigem ostwind zu
uns bringt und gleichzeitig ein tief das
eben sehr milde und leichte luft über
diese kältere schicht schiebt und dann
eben halt diese enormen schneefälle
bringt so was erlebt man ganz selten
vielleicht alle 20 30 40 jahren mal und
das gefährlich ist vor allen dingen der
eisregen dem eis kann auch bei
temperaturen unter null grad wasser kann
auch bei temperaturen unter null grad
flüssig bleiben und wenn es dann auf den
gefrorenen boden fällt dann geht es ganz
schnell spiegelglatt und das ist eben
ganz aktuell das gefährt dann gucken wir
doch mal auf die ganz aktuelle lage wo
ist denn im moment am schlimmsten am
schlimmsten ist es aktuell vor allen
dingen im mittleren hessen dazu habe ich
eine karte mitgebracht da kann man das
ganz schön sehen
man sieht weiter im norden ist es regen
und es ist ganz heftiger ostwind und was
man natürlich auch nicht vernachlässigen
darf ist der kräftige regen im südwesten
haben der immer noch eine hochwasserlage
und dann kommt man auch wie sich das
weiter entwickeln wird jetzt in der
kommenden nacht und dann auch morgen am
sonntag also in der nacht zieht dieser
schnee weiter nach norden das sieht man
auf dieser grafik ganz schön und die
eisregen fläche wird sich auch ein
bisschen weiter verändern also ist vor
allen dingen auch die oberpfalz
betroffen und morgen über tag wird sich
der eisregen langsam dann in richtung
nordwesten verschieben soll aber heißen
es bleibt die ganze zeit glatt und
morgen schneit ist die ganze zeit weiter
und die frage ist ja was gewinnt denn
gewinnt die kälte oder gewillt die milde
luft uns gewinnt eindeutig die kälte
also ab montag wird nur noch schnee und
dann haben wir dauerfrost -10 natürlich
temperaturen in deutschland also ein
problem das jetzt nicht nur ein paar
stunden anhält sondern wir uns wirklich
über tage darauf einstellen müssen
katja vielen dank und dann zu unserem
nächsten thema heute abend es gibt in
der kroner krise ein ganzes konzert von
meinungen und ratschläge
manchmal muss man von kakophonie
sprechen in einem punkt aber scheinen
sich die handelnden personen den
staatskanzleien ministerien und
kanzleramt mittlerweile ziemlich einig
zu sein wenn wir in der aktuellen
situation lockern dann tun wir das
zuerst bei schulen und kita
speziell für die kleineren und deren
bildungschancen auch der bundespräsident
ruft heute dazu auf und mahnt die
politik jungen leuten eine zukunft nach
corona zu eröffnen
es sieht heute so aus als würde sich da
ab mittwoch etwas tun wenn kanzlerin
ministerpräsidentinnen
ministerpräsidenten sich wieder zusammen
schalten wie die diskussion in den kitas
ankommt zeigt wollen ihn jetzt zu einem
beispiel in hannover basteln trösten und
jetzt im winter immer wieder kleine
verschnupfte nasen abputzen erzählt tino
pohl hat arbeitet quasi an vorderster
viren front in einer kita in hannover
abstand halten kaum möglich aus
pädagogischen gründen tragen sie hier im
umgang mit den kleinsten keine maske
das würden die kinder nicht verstehen
sich schützend vor einer infektion ist
kaum möglich
ja auf jeden fall habe ich angst also es
das arbeiten zurzeit ist ein spagat auf
der einen seite versucht man natürlich
gesund zu bleiben und man hat die sorge
davor sich anzustecken und zu erkranken
auf der anderen seite versuchen wir
natürlich unseren teil zum system
beizutragen
vor einem monat erkrankte pohl an cupid
19 auch eine kollegin in der kita
infizierte sich mit corona insgesamt
steigt das bewusstsein dass sie hier
einen hohen ansteckungsrisiko ausgesetzt
sind ich habe mich im dezember
angesteckt wodurch ich noch mal ein
bisschen wach gerüttelt wurde und mir
bewusst wurde dass die gefahr hier sehr
hoch ist eine vor kurzem veröffentlichte
aok studie kommt zu dem ergebnis dass
insbesondere berufsgruppen in der
kindererziehung am stärksten von
corvette 19 betroffen sind 2672 von
100000 erzieherin fehlten letztes jahr
zwischen märz und oktober
krankheitsbedingt wegen corona damit
liegt der wert 2,2 fach über dem
durchschnittswert
das risiko ist real große sorgen macht
sich auch tagesmutter im müll nutzer sie
hat einen brief an den
bundesgesundheitsminister geschrieben
erzieher müssten besser geschützt werden
fordert sie in der betreuung sei sie
eine
täglichen risiko mit vielen kontakten
ausgesetzt privat sollen sich die bürger
aber einschränken den kontakt massiv
reduzieren ein widerspruch findet sie
jetzt steigt die gefahr rasant jetzt
kommen noch diverse andere mutanten dazu
und jetzt bin ich irgendwie nicht mehr
bereit zu sagen das tragen wir auch noch
mit erzieherin minister vermissen die
politische rückendeckung sowie eine
perspektive viele erzieherinnen als der
beschäftigte machen sich sorgen um ihre
eigene gesundheit und die ihrer familien
um die viren mutation verschärfen die
situation nochmal wir halten es für
dringend geboten dass die erzieherinnen
dass die kita-beschäftigten
frühstmöglich sich impfen lassen können
wie vergleichsweise anderer gefährdete
berufsgruppen ein schnelleres impfen
würde vielen erzieherin die angst bei
der arbeit nehmen denn bislang zählen
pädagogen in der prioritätenliste nicht
zu den ersten beiden gruppen die geimpft
werden und das thema impfen nämlich
nehmen wir jetzt gleich auf die neuen
entwicklungen in sachen impfstoff hat
calvin blick ja für unter 16-jährige
gibt es ja doch keinen geeigneten
impfstoff was gerade für kinder und
jugendliche mit vorerkrankungen
problematisch ist nun hat
gesundheitsminister spanien mittel für
sommer in aussicht gestellt er wisse von
mehreren herstellern bei denen
entsprechende studien laufen schon jetzt
können besonders gefährdete erwachsene
unter 65 auf eine rasche impfung hoffen
denn der für sie vorgesehene impfstoff
von astrazeneca wurde erstmals nach
deutschland geliefert insgesamt knapp
350.000 dosen für viele kommen die
impfungen zu spät allein in deutschland
sind schon mehr als 60.000 menschen an
oder mit cupid 19 gestorben
für sie soll es am 18 april eine
zentrale gedenkfeier geben das hat
bundespräsident steinmeier
bekanntgegeben
damit wolle man in würde abschied nehmen
und den hinterbliebenen eine stimme
geben sagte er der rheinischen post
nach dem militärputsch in myanmar wächst
der widerstand der bürger mit jedem tag
heute gingen erstmals tausende offen
gegen die machthaber auf die straße
sie forderten die freilassung von de
facto regierungschef in sanssouci um die
proteste zu erschweren schalteten die
militärs landesweit das internet ab sie
begründen ihren putsch mit angeblichen
manipulationen bei der parlamentswahl
die hatte suu kyis partei haushoch
gewonnen
in den usa erhalten auch ehemalige
präsidentin einige
geheimdienstinformationen bei donald
trump könnte das anders sein denn sein
nachfolger beiden will ihm den zugang
verwehren
als grund nannte er in einem
fernsehinterview trumps unberechenbares
verhalten dessen umgang mit geheimen
informationen hatte schon während seiner
amtszeit für kritik gesorgt
jedes jahr werden mutwillig die
genitalien von millionen mädchen
verstümmelt darauf machen heute
zahlreiche organisationen aufmerksam
am internationalen tag gegen
genitalverstümmelung weltweit wird die
zahl der beschnittenen frauen und
mädchen auf 200 millionen geschätzt in
deutschland auf fast 70.000 die
betroffenen leiden oft unter chronischen
schmerzen und traumata einige werden
unfruchtbar oder sterben durch den
eingriff den landesparteitag der afg in
sachsen dürfte sich heute auch der
verfassungsschutz genauer angesehen
haben
denn die partei dort ist als
rechtsextremer verdachtsfall eingestuft
sachsen gilt innerhalb der afg als einer
der radikalsten landesverbände mit
besonders vielen akteuren die zum
sogenannten flügel zellen einer
parteiinternen vereinigung die sich
offiziell aufgelöst hatte
sachsen ist jetzt das vierte bundesland
in dem die dortige afd mit
nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
beobachtet werden kann
ob das im superwahljahr auch für die
gesamtpartei gelten wird ist noch offen
eine entscheidung darüber soll aber bald
fallen
thema bei der afg in sachsen war das
heute allemal wie cornelia schiemenz
zeigt alexander gauland
ehrenvorsitzender der afg ist ziemlich
sauer
und das durfte heute jeder hören in
seiner rede auf dem präsenz parteitag
der sächsischen fdp kam er schnell zur
sache die hochstufung des
landesverbandes zum verdachtsfall sei 1
eine regierung die sich immer öfter
nicht ans grundgesetz halten will jetzt
der opposition die sich ausdrücklich
daran hält den verfassungsschutz auf den
hals nach 15 jahren merkel ist
verfassungstreue verfassungsfeindlich
beworben
der verfassungsschutz beobachtet die
landesverbände in sachsen anhalt
thüringen brandenburg und nun auch in
sachsen außerdem seit vergangenem jahr
den flügel sowie die jugendorganisation
junge alternative für deutschland die
radikalen der partei sammeln sich im
offiziell aufgelösten flügel
zudem zählen sich besonders viele fdp
mitglieder in sachsen immer wieder
fallen sie mit rechten parolen auf sind
wenn überhaupt fachkräfte für
sozialbetrug mit der heraufstufung zum
verdachtsfall darf der verfassungsschutz
mit telefonüberwachungen oder
observationsaufgaben die partei reichte
strafanzeige ein wegen verdachtsfall
veröffentlichung dem verfassungsschutz
sachsen wird die partei vor die
verwaltungsabläufe seien ausgesprochen
schlecht organisiert und kontrolliert
die öffentlichmachung der information
afd ist verdachtsfall verfolge eine
andere zielsetzung als diejenige
rechtskonform informationen zu sammeln
um eine beurteilung zu entwickeln im
klartext die afg fürchtet nachteile im
superwahljahr
die beobachtung einer partei durch den
verfassungsschutz ist kein mittel des
politischen wettbewerbs sondern das ist
eine behördenentscheidung das ist die
entscheidung eines amtes entlang von
recht und gesetz zum schutze unserer
demokratie in berlin wird derzeit
geprüft die gesamte afd zum
verdachtsfall zu erheben die zeichen
stehen auf beobachtung auch im bund
einfach weil die koordination zwischen
den verschiedenen ämtern des
verfassungsschutzes ja auch auf
kooperationen eben angelegt ist und es
wenig sinn macht wenn die einen
beobachten und die anderen nicht
auf dem parteitag in dresden gilt die
parole jetzt erst recht
das ziel für die bundestagswahl 30
prozent der stimmen in sachsen
schauen wir wie immer samstags noch kurz
auf die lottozahlen auch dieses mal ohne
gewähr
8 12 23 38 41 48 superzahl 9 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text und zum schluss schauen wir noch
mal auf das extreme wetter in
deutschland denn es seien noch einmal
gewarnt die lage bleibt angespannt
morgen schneit es in der mitte teils
anhaltend und kräftig weiter bei starkem
ostwind kommt es zu extremen
schneeverwehungen im süden regnet es von
der eifel bis zur oberpfalz kann es auch
eisregen geben
im stürmischen norden bleibt es meist
trocken nördlich des mains werden minus
sieben bis plus 0 grad erreicht sonst 1
bis 11 grad
die neue woche beginnt dann etwas
sanfter doch auch dann kann es noch
leicht schneien dazu gibt es im norden
eisige höchsttemperaturen von minus 10
grad im süden deutlich wärmer mit plus 7
grad habe ich eben gerade plus null grad
gesagt dass man die höchsttemperaturen
unglaublich höchsten
was für ein wetter fernseh wetter in
jedem fall wenn sie irgendwie können
bleiben sie einfach zu hause wir würden
uns auf jeden fall auch morgen wieder
auf sie freuen und für heute bedanken
uns ganz herzlich dass sie dabei waren
[Musik]